[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and I think we just
found something really interesting about
code geass season 3 I want to thank
anime world who commented on our last
livestream today and mentioned that he
found what looks like a new pv teaser ad
that was posted on a Twitter video on a
Japanese account a Japanese Twitter
account anime world wanted us to check
this video and see if we could find some
clues for code geass season 3 and we
think we did it appears that this ad was
posted in a subway or a train station in
Japan and someone recorded it on their
phone and posted it on Twitter I'm going
to be taking a look at this pv teaser
advertisement right now there are two
clips of it on Twitter one is a head-on
clip but does not have audio so we will
be looking at that one first and I will
be talking over it and then at the end
of this video I will play the other
version which is sideways but it does
contain the full audio so you can listen
for yourself as always we are staying on
top of all of the news and updates for
code geass season 3 so if you are new to
the channel be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you will
always be the first to know this trailer
begins with you cannot the Japanese
voice actress 4c - and she greets
everyone and tells them to continue to
support the Code Geass franchise now pay
attention to the Geass sequence at the
beginning of this teaser you know those
lines that flash the animation that is
shown when Geass is being used in the
original series you will see that at the
beginning of this teaser the Geass
sequence is the same as in the original
series this is important so pay
attention we see zero there and there's
this biast there's the Geass sequence
you see those lines you recognize them
from the original series and then we see
a sort of mosaic a bunch of different
clips from different Code Geass mediums
first we see 2006 the original r1 then
2008 the end of r2
after that we see 2010 alky 2d exile the
OVA then we see a bunch of the manga
flashing by including Renia of the
darkness and all the reflection after
that we see some live action plays of
Code Geass and we see Nunnally in
wonderland and then 2016 look at that
2016 2017 we see a bunch of things flash
and then look at this Geass sequence
look at the line look how different they
are this is important this is a
different type of Geass sequence then at
the beginning then in the original show
if you look at the lines they are more
squiggly they almost look like sperm
cells or something why let's continue
watching so then we see some writing and
I will talk about the writing in a
minute and it ends off with this scene
this clip of C - kissing Lelouch from
the original series now that scene with
C - and Lelouch doesn't tell us much
it's a clip from the original series and
it could be indicating that this teaser
is primarily for the recap films however
we do think that we found some new
information and also this clip being
shown at this time could hint that
illusion C - shipping is gonna be canon
but moving on looking at the writing I
asked for some help on our discord
server and I want to thank at ado and
coup D Gohan for helping me decipher
some of the writing here and essentially
what the writing was telling us was that
the Code Geass story is going further in
2017 the world shall be given Geass
again the story of the boy Lelouch shall
continue code geass as awaited third
chapter is in production 2017 is the
start of a new day a new age so so to
speak so this is really interesting
because referring to r3 or Code Geass
season 3 the sequel as a third chapter
knowing that we had chapter 1 R 1
chapter 2 R 2 is to me a good sign in
terms of getting a full season because
if the chapters are roughly the same
length then the chapter 3 chapter 3
should not be just a film or something
it should be a full third season so of
course we're all hoping that that is
going to happen now if you happen to
speak Japanese fluently and you can read
the text and you see that I missed
something in the writing please feel
free to let me know down in the comments
a whole bunch of images flash by really
quickly in this teaser trailer and the
quality is not the best so it is hard to
decipher all of them but I did notice
this I noticed that when it says 2016 we
see an image of the eye the same eye
that we saw in the PV back in December
it is the ID that is that was said to
have turned green
so the Geass was set to have turned
green before turning red again so this
is the eye this little brief scene and
clip from the original PV that made
people think that there would be a green
Geass a different form of Diaz so that
eye is here and then when that
transitions to 2017 from another angle
we can see this image now I am not sure
who this is the only person that it kind
of looks like is a quito from Akito the
exiled but why would a quito appear in
the sequence where it says 2017 he would
not be appearing in the recap films so
does that mean that a quito might be
appearing in the actual sequel we don't
know it's not enough to go on but it
could be a clue so I'd like to know what
you guys think about that particular
thing let me know down in the comments
and remember earlier that I said pay
attention to the Geass sequence the one
at the beginning of the teaser and the
one at the end because they're different
the one at the beginning is like the
original show the one at the end is
different the lines are different I have
put up a comparison of the two right
here so check it out left is the
original right is the new one and you
can see that the one on the right is
very different it is clearly more
squiggly the lines are different so this
to me says that this could be hinting at
a different form of Geass power because
we know it's not just an artistic change
you know they're going to change it
completely now from the one to the other
in the new movies because they show both
in this tea
the old version and new version so that
tells me that perhaps connected with the
whole green icing they might be hinting
and a new different form of Geass here
and yes yes I can hear some of you guys
thinking whoa those lines there kind of
look like sperm cells so could this be a
clue that c2 and Lelouch are going to
have a baby the big question that so
many of you want to know of course we
don't know but you can go crazy with the
theories down in the comments so yeah
this teaser doesn't give us that much to
go on but I think there are some clues
here the different Geass sequence the
aki to--like character that appears
beside the year 2017 and the third
chapter reference so yeah definitely let
me know what you think let me know if
you found any additional clues a big
thank you goes then for helping me look
through this teaser and find these clues
thanks again to anime world and thank
you to a taro and Cory Gohan from the
discord for helping me out with the
translation if you want to stay up to
date on all the latest code geass season
3 news and updates be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell and now I
will play the full clip of the teaser
from another angle with working audio
credit - this goes to the Japanese
Twitter account at Sheena underscore X X
underscore and I will leave the link to
that in the description as always thank
you so much for watching and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
by my uncle if your own materials in
this mausoleum - protein trucks go down
uses a urologist experiment you cannot
be scored of the ability to are yes I'm
okay no forgiving the experience right
for the relief in fact for any
interference in tradition - jinwu /
maybe also to have been charged on of a
factually incorrect code against
corrosion of cosmic seed oil right now
right now college show you must use
common agreement
[Music]
old man like you doesn't know needs most
refuse
[Music]
I do like to let anyone
the high requesting an item from United
people do not know about how to use your
include all to shape American cookie
enjoyment and a show me your cream your
condoms
[Music]
show them show them coke okay honey
[Music]
honey orange
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]